well this is day 20 of the partial
government shutdown caused by the
standoff over paying for the wall the
deadlock may be putting the US food
supply at risk the Food and Drug
Administration normally does about 160
routine food inspections a week since
the shutdown began inspections have been
sharply reduced and a Warner's here with
the potential impact on what we eat and
a good morning good morning bianna the
FDA says it's working to bring back
about a hundred and fifty employees to
restart inspections of high-risk
facilities as early as next week
but inspections of routine facilities
are at a standstill the FDA regulates
about 75% of the u.s. food supply
roughly 31% of the food they deal with
is considered to be high risk that
includes baby formula seafood cheese and
produce now FDA inspectors look for
issues at processing facilities like
unsanitary conditions and infestations
they also inspect food for Salmonella
and e-coli contamination the Centers for
Disease Control and Prevention estimates
forty eight million people in the u.s.
gets sick each year from food borne
diseases about 3,000 died late last year
an e.coli outbreak linked to romaine
lettuce sickened more than 60 people the
FDA says that outbreak appears to be
over but their investigation into it is
ongoing now despite the shutdown the FDA
says it's still conducting foreign food
inspections inspections at ports and is
dealing with recalls and outbreaks the
Department of Agriculture says its
inspections of meat poultry and eggs
will also continue Gale all right got it
Anna thank you